Las Vegas mother is holding on to hope
to find her missing son but her
frustration is also growing and what she
says was the lack of urgency from police
to find 26 year old Colin best Colin is
both autistic and bipolar his mom is his
legal guardian he was arrested and
released on his own the same day he was
reported missing Victoria Saha joins us
from downtown Las Vegas with the latest
on the search Victoria
here at Clark County Detention Center is
where Colin's mom says things went wrong
Colin was released at 1 30 a.m on Sunday
January 29th but he was also reported
missing in that same day and no one has
seen him since
not going to give up until I find my son
Jennifer best is living another day of
agony without her son Colin we have no
idea where Colin is we have no idea if
he's safe we have nothing to go off of
Jennifer tells us she reported Colin
missing on the morning of Saturday
January 28th and made it clear to
officers that her son was off his meds
and she is his legal guardian that night
Colin was arrested for disorderly
conduct and resisting a public officer
he was released hours later and
Jennifer's upset no one called her who
do things to blame here I mean I think I
would actually blame them all because
like both both Metro and the Detention
Center both dropped the ball or whatever
you did have you seen him in the area
after we first reported our story on
call in Thursday night Metro released
pictures of Colin on Fremont Street
Jennifer says this was after her son was
released from jail makes no sense he
walked into the crowd and then now he's
gone Jenna ever says on Monday morning
under Sheriff Andrew Walsh let her in on
their briefing about Colin and says
things are finally moving along but she
believes if Colin was released to her
after his arrest he would be home safe
right now it's the same people that
allowed this to happen are the ones I'm
working with now and I'm supposed to put
my trust back into it and every day that
goes by is another date where Colin
could be in danger his mental capacity
diminishes even more and more so right
now he's at the age of a five-year-old
I've been trying to get answers from
Metro on why they didn't call Jennifer
when Colin was arrested but they tell me
they can't comment on that but just
moments ago that we did learn that Metro
is putting up a ten thousand dollar
reward for anyone who comes forward with
information that can lead them to call
in reporting from Clark County Detention
Center Victoria Saha 8 News Now